welcome thanks for coming uh I'm a
developer advocate the IBM Watson data
platform so we do a lot of work with
manage databases and analytics and
through the course of that work we built
this tool called pixie dust which is
this which is the topic of this talk but
it's kind of this is a short talk and
pixie dust is a big is a big project
with a lot of different implications so
the talk is going to be half code demo
half sort of motivation behind why I
think it's important and what I hope to
get out I'm doing a lot of motivation
because they don't have enough time to
show you encode all the things that are
cool about it but I want to encourage
you give you enough reason to go back
and either becoming youth take the time
to become a big user or even become a
big developer on the project so jumping
right in so Harvard Business Review I
really like because unlike some of the
tech magazines it's it's a little bit
more down-to-earth and more useful
what they say but I want to start off
with this one about data-driven decision
making the rise is real but uneven and
so you know this is it's a real movement
data-driven decision making is is making
big inroads into corporations relying
less on intuition and more on data and
you'll see here this graphic from the
article so in one industry US
manufacturing 2005 about 5 percent usage
of data-driven decision-making and go up
to 2010 and it triples so it's
definitely something that's you know
that was a while ago now I think it's
even bigger but I think the most
interesting thing to me was that the
rise is uneven and why is that and I
think that's a people issue how I can
use this clicker and this is what
this is how it really relates to us data
science is you know a really hot hot
field suppose if somebody said a year or
two ago that it was the sexiest
profession around right now but the data
problems tomorrow cannot be solved by
data scientists alone and this is one of
the key themes to this
so as the data-driven decision-making
movement grows us the people in this
room we're being pressured to know a lot
of stuff and do even more so I don't
know how many people in here consider
themselves a web developer at developer
some kind of developer for you and how
many consider themselves statisticians
or and then data does anybody consider
themselves a data scientist yeah a lot
okay and then what's the last one a
mathematician anybody consider
themselves a mathematician okay and how
many people feel like they have to be
all for those things to do their job
great because the whole the theme of the
first part of this talk is how stressed
out being in our job is right now so we
used to just have to do one of these
things build a web application or build
a data visualization or or build a
machine learning model now I think we're
being asked to build or tomorrow we'll
be being asked to build combinations of
those put all those together to create
solutions or applications and not only
build them but also be stable scalable
extensible and methodologically valid
and they're going to have to do all
these things because these will be
mission critical systems the businesses
are going to be riding on them
so you know how do we do this how do we
how do we work to blur the lines between
developers and data science scientists
and statisticians so for the half of you
who aren't being asked to do this if you
weren't stressed in before you walked in
but but you are now I think I'm sorry
but I think you have to be as I said you
know JavaScript frameworks every
language database backends we need to
know all these things at once and then
add in the data science languages and
are in Scala and Python and all the
databases that go with them and then put
on top of that machine learning models
and I don't know about you but I just
want to go be a furniture maker
sometimes but if you're not ready to do
that which I'm sort of 50/50 myself and
you want to try to make these work in an
organization I'm going to go through a
little story about how we're building
pixie-dust this tool which helps to
bridge the gap but before we do that I
want to talk a little bit about a little
bit about how we see organizations
that's wasn't supposed to happen so when
I came into IBM a few years ago just
three years ago we talked a lot about
this system three types of system
systems of engagement systems of record
and systems of operation now spend a
little time in this good I think it's
really important in understanding
technology so systems of record or
generally what what a business what runs
a business if you're in retail your
point-of-sale systems you have to track
you know who's buying what you have to
track the sale you have to take that
back to the inventory and get the
product out to the person you have
employees so you need ERP and HR systems
you have CRM systems and all of those
are sort of record the actions of the
business system is engagement are ways
in which you you know not really quite
how the business run
the business but ways in which you reach
out to customers maybe or partners
you'll have you know social media
applications and websites and partner
partner channel management applications
and a bunch of stuff there and then
systems our operation are really about
systems that that instrument the stuff
the hardware you might have if you're
you know shipping stuff around the world
you may have systems that monitor your
you know fleet management systems and
monitor your trucking trucking if you
have industrial equipment if you have
pipelines and things like that you'll
have you'll have technology that
monitors flow rates of water and the
heat of pipe pumps and things like that
so all these come together or you know
back back before things got more
complicated they just you bought an acid
compliant database for your system
record and it never talked to the other
stuff like there was no way to get
information from your point of sale into
your marketing campaign which is a
system of engagement why is this thing
concrete but now more and more you know
as we be as we're being asked to make
data-driven decisions you're going to
want to know you're going to need to
combine all these so for example if you
have a customer let's say your gap and
you have a customer who has a gap card
so you know who they are when they check
out on the website and they put in an
order for you know a pair of jeans
you're going to want to that's in your
system a record and you're going to want
to be able to feed your system
engagement so next week your marketing
people can send them an email saying hey
this this shirt goes well with the jeans
you just bought last week and that's the
kind of data-driven decision-making
we're trying to we're trying to create
and what we need to do do all that is
systems of orchestration which don't
exist yet and so my pitch to you is that
the pixie dust
open-source framework that we built on
top of Jupiter notebooks is the
beginnings of a way to stitch together
these systems to create a system of
orchestration so I'm going to to further
convince you that this is worth getting
digging really deep into I'm going to
tell a story about a project and we're
going to start off with the people
involved so we got then the full stack
developer pretty experienced in in his
job got a master's degree in computer
science a lot of experience programming
knows some core languages and some
front-end stuff and some core databases
and them sequel and relational stuff and
then we have how and here's his model
best line of code is the one I didn't
have to write and the Tasha is the data
scientist she's a mathematician by
training which but she's got some good
experience with big data work and
machine learning and she you know she
knows some coding Python and our but
software engineering is really not her
her specialty and she loves data so
here's this story that all of a sudden
surprise meeting with the VP of
development with his two big two biggest
hotshots Natasha and Ben so we have an
urgent need to build an application for
marketing that can provide real-time
sentiment analysis on Twitter data so
you've got six weeks to build it and
your target consumers marketing staff so
it must be easy to use and it must scale
out-of-the-box so look at using Apache
spark which neither one of you have ever
used before so they start brainstorming
okay so Ben's the full stack developer
you know familiar with Twitter API is
I'll work on data acquisition from
Twitter and enrichment with sentiment
analysis and scoring using scoring using
sparks streaming I know Java but I don't
know don't know Python I'm trying to
learn on this project and but Scala is
very close to Java so that might be
possible
Natacha can do the data exploitation
analysis
this and she knows Python and our and
she likes pandas a numpy but you know
able to dig in the spark if it helps so
this clicker is okay so how can they
collaborate they have different lengths
they know different languages they have
different skill sets you know a little
bit of Technology overlap but they can't
for example work on the same they can't
both be told okay you're going to you
know build a big Java project and and
work on the same collaborative codebase
there so our idea is how can we use
Jupiter notebooks to to help them
collaborate and create sort of
orchestrate the work between a
full-stack developer and a data science
scientists I'm going to skip this
because I think from being this
conference for a day everybody knows
about Jupiter notebooks right
this is for a really different audience
some background on Jupiter notebooks and
how it works
spark is everybody good with spark
probably better than me so basically
spark is not a database it's a it almost
sort of manages your storage and figures
out how to how to distribute jobs across
any number of databases or flat files
that you can that actually store the
information but what's important here is
the whole combination of all this so you
know if you look at the business chart I
talked about the Venn diagram I talked
about with systems of engagement and
record and and operation you'll see a
lot of those ideas expressed in
technology here so spark is really well
positioned as a sort of Orchestrator for
all these things spark allows you to or
at least the ecosystem we built up
around spark in jupiter notebooks allows
you to interact with data that's the
spark you know
spark Clark and the notebook level
you're able to bring in a lot of
libraries that cover you know things
you'd want to do an analytical task
you'd want to do in a lot of those
different systems stats math machine
learning just visualization and in a
notebook you know with Python coding you
can obviously reach out to Web API s and
bring in a lot of services that you
might want to use can that's spelled
wrong comedy that should be cognitive so
you know with IBM and Watson we do a lot
of we're going to reach out a lot to
Watson Watson services to do some
natural language processing and
sentiment score and things like that so
you know we found that this ecosystem
around Jupiter notebooks and spark is
really well-suited to orchestrating all
those areas of business so Ben's never
seen no books but they seem pretty
powerful but they look complicated for a
development course remember he doesn't
know Python but he can write some good
Java code so this is where we start
talking about code finally so pixie-dust
finally talked about this so pixie dust
the thing Ben is going to love about
pixie dust is he can write an
application that pulls in Twitter data
does all that does all the interaction
with the Twitter API gets back all the
tweets and you can just package that up
into a jar and pixie dust will allow
that jar to be brought directly into the
notebook and sort of run and run it as
an application will also see pixie dust
as a helper library so that if you're
familiar been working in Jupiter
notebooks and doing a lot of
visualization with matplotlib or bouquet
you can you know be highly focused on
your tasks of analysis and then just
lose a half a day on learning how to get
some line in the right place in
matplotlib
and pixie dust visualization library is
designed to automate a lot of
stuff and get rid of you know stop the
context switching for going in to figure
out how to make a chart a bar chart or a
pie chart or all it's not perfect you'll
get a lot of text overlaps and all but
it's great for getting the you know
roughing out your analysis roughing out
the full thing maybe you'll have to go
back in later and do some hand coding of
hand Python coding of the to get the
exact look and feel the chart you want
but it does a great job of my guess
exploratory visualization and then
there's some other helper things that
have built in that like download and
export data using Scala I'm not I'm not
a scholar programmer so the lead
developer of pixie-dust finds us really
useful he's an amazing developer but
being able to share variables between
between Scala and Python let's say
there's some library you really want to
use in Scala it's not available in
Python but you really want to go back
and forth between those two you can do
that with pixie dust and that's some
weird magic that I own leavin I can't
even explain how that works
so I'm going to jump into the demo mode
a little bit
I'll show you how Ben
just looking at looking good how Ben
gets the gets the Twitter streams into a
notebook so here I am how am I on time
by the way okay okay
so this notebook is sort of
self-contained a lot of what I'm talking
about is in here and documentation I'll
go through the architecture a little bit
first so we talked about this a little
bit so Twitter data is going to come in
as an input stream into spark that's
going to be a program that's written and
then it's going to be enriched with
emotional tone scores using by reaching
out to Watson tone analyzer service and
then it's going to come into the
notebook as processed data let's see how
that works so we're going to install
Python Twitter and Watson developer
cloud
and then pixie dust so now I'm going to
import pixie dust and you'll see this
jar path here github.com IBM Watson data
Lab spark samples raw master disk
streaming Twitter assembly 1.6 jar so
streaming Twitter assembly is the thing
that been built that pulls in all that
Twitter data and I'm just going to pull
it in pixie dust install package will
pull that in I'm not going to restart my
kernel because it wasn't upgraded it was
already in here so Scala bridge is going
to so I'm going to run this quick and
scroll my credentials off the screen so
Scala bridge is allowing me to put even
though I'm in a Python environment in my
notebook this program that Ben rode is
in Scala and I can set some environment
variables for my Twitter my Twitter API
access tokens I can set some environment
variables from within Python in the
Scala back into the Scala environment
then we're going to instantiate our
spark context so right here % % Scala
here here where we instantiate that
streaming Twitter application as the
variable called demo and then we set all
these environment variables these
variables we're going to need to use the
Twitter service and the Watson tone
analyzer service and then this at the
end of the cell demo dot start Twitter
streaming it's going to run the
application for 30 seconds stream in
Twitter data for 30 seconds
so we'll wait for 30 seconds hopefully
it's working
so starting Twitter stream I have no
this is actually live I have no idea
what sometimes there's some bad words
and Twitter streams so it's not my fault
ok so now we're going to now we're going
to create a data frame out of this
Twitter stream which is pretty cool
because remember the Twitter application
is in written in scala and we're going
to bring it into pi spark Python in
spark
so you'll see Twitter stream stock batch
completed 209 records Twitter stream
stop you can now create a sequel context
and data frame with 158 tweets and now
we'll do that and then you can do and
this is where the handoff to natasha
comes so now she's got now she's
comfortable she has a Python data frame
or a PI spark data frame and she can go
in you know do do data visualizations to
her heart's desire and so first we're
just going to do some you know basic
stuff you'll probably always do group
the tweets by user author and user ID
this is just regular regular Python a
regular PI spark you'll see here some
cool things about the Watson tone
analyzer so these tweets are you know
scored for anger and disgust and this is
really interesting so the idea I didn't
really talk about this much but the
marketing department wants this because
they want some idea of what you know how
people are feeling about their products
and this is something that actually
comes up things like situations like a
couple years ago Volkswagen had that big
fraud problem with how they talked about
their diesel engines fuel economy rating
or for your economy performance and they
got a lot of and to be able to
understand what they wanted to do to you
know counteract that bad publicity in
the marketplace they could have used
something like this to understand how
people were reacting
I'm not going to explain every line of
this the link to this you can run this
yourself this is all in github but what
I want to get to so now we're going to
call Watson personality insights on the
text and try to get an idea of what kind
of person they are there's some really
interesting stuff eventually in here
we're going to compare this to Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton because we
originally built this this demo about
six months ago and that was a more of an
interesting topic
so I got to wait for the wait for the
backend sparking engine to catch up with
me here we go
so here's the first look at the pixie
dust display visualization features
I got to drive this thing here so what I
did here is I made a chart a bar chart
using the bouquet library and if I go
all this so we're still in a jupiter
notebook cell but you have a lot of user
interface goodness in here you've got
this little graphical menu here with a
little table icon and the line chart
thing if i do the drop down here you'll
see for any data frame you have all
these options or in etosha would have
all these options for quickly displaying
a visualizing data bar chart line chart
scatterplot pie chart maps if you have
latitude longitude in your data frame
you can make maps out of it that's the
part i actually worked on so here we
chose to do a bouquet chart so these
users in our sample tweets database
these are how the these are how they
come out in terms of their personality
around whether they need closeness or
they need curiosity I can go in here and
change my render at a map pot lid see
you'll see while you spoke a because it
looks a little nicer
I could also just look at the table as a
data as a table which this is really
nice if you hate the way if you hate the
way you just you know sort of quickly
look at your data frames in in a jupiter
notebook this is a really nice little
very nice way now right now we're
limited to go back to options right now
we are limited to how many rows we show
you we're showing only a hundred rows
but we'd like to build you know you can
jump in this is an open source project
you could jump in help us make the table
the table widget more useful let's go
back to the bar chart so you can see how
fun this is versus you know coding a
million spending hours and hours coding
different visualizations just to you
know quickly switch between bar charts
and line charts and pie charts
okay then we'll move in here compare
Twitter users personality insight scores
with last year's presidential candidates
this is just a fun thing I'm not going
to spend a lot of time here then you can
get all that you know normal stuff you
do but I need to move to the end here so
you can go in and you know look at look
at the how this was done if you're
interested in more detail
but I'm going to jump back to the
presentation so basically you get the
idea all the things you'd normally do in
data sight so we brought in from the
Twitter streaming API we brought in all
this data and then in the end web
developer built that application then we
brought it into the Python environment
and there's lots of there's a lot of
really interesting little functions in
here that you can grab and use if you're
interested
the header column headers again others
Hilton all weathers defined so the
question was the personally personality
in site types anger disgust fear joy
said did did are the user definable or
were they no they were given to us by
Watson personnel Ally insight service
those are all built into the service so
yeah this whole whole nother talk I
could do around some a whole nother
forty minutes on the lots impersonating
personality insights service recommend
perpetual line of potentials of spaces
for engagement with the personalities
because I could be saved things that
needs community needs closeness so it's
a basically telling me of the intimus
but this character based on the tweeter
analysis of the tutor of what's going
down
or analysis of the trees is the kind of
person you want to engage with yeah one
example I have in another presentation
is let's say you have a lot one thing
companies like to do is they have guest
bloggers you know star bloggers publish
content around you know create better
brand awareness and create some you know
affinity with people who are already
famous so you might use a person against
personality insights to find out which
of your customers are extroverts and
those people you might you know send
them a travel blog or something like
that you might send them something
associated with that versus somebody who
has more of a introverted personality
who you know may be interested in a
whole nother field of stuff so if you
have three different star bloggers that
you were that you could assign to
different customers you could use
personal insights to figure out how to
make that most effective
so I'm going to jump back into the
presentation because this was you know
this looks pretty useful so they go back
to the VP I think here what happened
here okay these are a little bit out of
order I went through some of these
already so you know the VP loves it you
saw some great tables and charts there
but the executives who are going to use
this are going to actually want to touch
it they're not going to want they're not
going to be able to write you know run
the notebook cells or tweak them they
want to be able to but they're going to
want to have some interactivity and be
able to do some filtering in real time
charting without writing any code so we
took pixie dust which is basically a
bunch of Python code to automate what
you would do in the cells already and
then but then at the end you're kind of
limited to what you can what you can how
you can operate it because you just have
the drop-down gooeys if you want to
change what data is showing you actually
have to change the data frame with
python so we created a another
extensibility layer called pixie apps
which lets you take the pixie dust code
and instantiate it or extend it into an
application environment I'm not
explaining this well but the idea is
that you can take those Python classes
and you can use them in an HTML
environment so it's almost like another
sort of templating language I'm just
going to quickly run through this and
get down to that cool part so this was
one way to do running through that
Jupiter notebook cell-by-cell was one
way to do this some to build this
application now put that aside for a
second there's a whole nother way to do
it built on the pixi app framework so
once again we're going to go in here
we're going to do demo equals pixie dust
streaming Twitter
we're going to set our environment
variables for Twitter access Watson tone
analyzer access we're going to install
we're going to pip install the
pixie-dust Twitter demo so this is I
don't in a forty minute presentation I
don't have enough time to show all the
code about how you do the HTML work just
working but so it's just right now it's
just a jar that gets installed but trust
me these are HTML this is a lot of HTML
in a Cell and there's some you know
extra tags in the HTML in the HTML
elements that let you pull in classes so
if you worked in any templating language
this is based on Jinja but any
templating language you know you extend
you can extend your HTML by putting in
new new attributes inside the inside the
div classes or things like this this is
not showing so well on the screen some
gray than showing but anyway so the same
way we I ran some code to start off the
Twitter feed now we have a user
interface to do it so I'm going to click
this button at the bottom start
streaming
and it starts kicking off before in the
cell you saw some of these messages now
you're going to see a new user interface
and you're actually going to see the
tweets coming in over here so this is
all stuff you can do depicts the app
framework
it's like hover over well it starts to
build a chart if I hover over the over a
tweet it'll show me the sentiment
analysis and the personality insights
this person has an extraversion or
emotional range of 4% joy 8% sadness so
this is I can filter I don't know what
I'd filter these tweets by but you'll
see you can have an application you can
build an application that automatically
creates the bar chart we're charting
based on some of these sentiment some of
these personality insight things if you
hover over here you'll just see
analytical agreeableness anger so I'm
going to stop streaming
expressed about your company's product
or service or this is just this is just
a demo applicate I think it's just it's
just pulling in the whole Twitter fire
hose or the DECA hose the 10% so it's
just grabbing whatever is coming through
Twitter right now and scouring it with
personality insights obviously if you
were building real application you would
you know start with your hashtags that
you're interested in only pull in that
data so this is just a proof of concept
but you can see so this you know all the
stuff we did in Python by hand we now
had a web developer do with HTML tags
and they'd have to spend probably a week
or so learning the our special
templating language but you can you know
web developer would be much more
comfortable doing that and you're still
actually in the Jupiter notebook your
your system is actually a dialog box
popping out of a cell so you know you've
created just to finish up here you've
created a system of orchestration you've
created one environment in which data
scientists and web developers can work
and be not be completely loosely coupled
like Web Services but be a little more
tightly coupled so that you can get more
work done and have the performance
benefits of having the spark backend for
big data you know which you can't really
get if you try to loosely couple your
your technology team through web api's
so you know understand it's a lot I
think for the last 10 years everything
was about you know loosely coupling your
team's through Web API s and everything
should have an API well that's great but
when you start getting into big data and
you want some real-time feedback and
performance and you want high
interactivity with the data like this
Web API is don't really cut it I don't
think
and so you need a platform that's sort
of closer to the metal in which web
furs and data scientists can still be
productive and that's what I think we've
we've delivered here and so there's just
end ok this is second just to summarize
I think you know pixie dust is an open
source output an open source framework
built on top of jupiter notebooks which
you can participate in pixie apps is a
another thing you can just learn and be
productive with and not even learn pixie
dust and then you can also help us build
out some of those features of pixie dust
so we can get more mapping features and
Bart reading features and all that great
stuff so thanks thanks for coming